who's our florida  deo secretary  we also have chancellor henry mack from  the florida department of education so  this part is more coveted like which is  when you speak speaking is more effort  than people might realize  and a lot of times with kovid  it's this having to really  labor each breath to keep speaking so  far later it seems more like he's almost  crying brad ferguson senior vp and  general manager skywater florida and  dale miller site director skywater  florida  as well as representative fred  hawkins manufacturing  is something that we need and you can  hear that breath is you know you you the  the  the multiple short breaths to try to  keep up with the oxygen he needs